what is going on there citizens of the
reject Nation we have I am Groot John
how are you I am Groot well before you
skip ahead to the reaction uh just gonna
give you guys a heads up since there are
five short films and they're remarkably
short films uh it's super short we are
just gonna do two videos out of this so
we're gonna watch episodes one through
three and that's gonna be in this video
and then the second video is going to be
episodes four and five that's how the
upload is gonna go on this but guys
thank you so much for being here with
that in mind subscribe and click that
notification Bell to become a citizen of
the reject Nation but mainly to get
notified what the reaction for four and
five are up here on the channel leave a
like that helps us out plenty doesn't
take too much on your end to ask for
also full-length Reaction watch along
three sync up with the time code or your
own copy or over at our patreon page for
super sexy rejects become a super sexy
reject today all right well let's get to
it but before that
the team had proper thank you for
helping us set up these down all right
now let's really get to it
[Music]
what huh
[Music]
VHS was in the 80s
wow that is beautiful
I saw the ship in the background there
foreign
[Laughter]
spa day
[Music]
and then baby Groot invented bath bombs
[Laughter]
wow this one like Avatar stuff beautiful
[Music]
wow
Chia Pet
s
okay
I am tree I am shrub
I am Groot
oh he likes it
[Music]
[Music]
it's kind of creepy
[Music]
huh
I swear
[Music]
[Music]
cool
yeah it takes some of his mud with you
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
I'm trying to sleep
hmm
[Music]
quiet squirrel bird
did you oh my
oh my God
dark sensibilities you got great yeah
[Music]
after all that he just stole it that's
hilarious that was that was very very
charming and a little twisted yeah I
like it the animation too is beautiful
indeed one indeed
yeah I gotta get a good misting in
[Music]
Peter puffs
it needs to repot him in a bigger pot
[Music]
[Applause]
wow guys
[Music]
possible
yeah he's a guy creepy
[Music]
help oh
[Music]
[Laughter]
no
[Music]
wow
[Music]
this is like my left foot with
my left Groot Daniel Day-Lewis did the
voices episode
what kind of wood's gonna pop out
it's wood you know what a joke that was
me uh
uh well you know say if you got big feet
[Music]
blank
a minute of planks every morning
downward dog
foreign
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
these are surprisingly super enjoyable I
know well I don't know why I'm so
surprised by how enjoyable these are
well because they're like classic in a
way like because you can't really speak
they go back to that just visual
storytelling you know animated
personality and you also don't get those
Pixar short films anymore you kind of
get that Vibe down oh yeah it feels like
they put their resources
[Music]
we've got group bathing the
Rebirth of this group
[Music]
traumatized Groot dark episode yeah
[Music]
the sci-fi horror ones yeah this is the
Dead Space episode
[Laughter]
dropping a log
[Music]
IC
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
dancing with the bark
try again oh
wow
that I could really improve your dancing
[Laughter]
guy's gonna freeze to death in the
vacuum of space I love the unexpected
dark humor man yes
brood is a prideful cast
oh God
that was fun
okay let's watch next series
I'm sad we're already more than halfway
with birthdays I hope they do more
I hope every year they do a few
uh we'll talk a little bit we're going
to the next two right now
um yeah that was um that was super fun
that what I'm really enjoying about it
right now is getting like I don't know
how necessary these chapters are in
groot's life but they're very enjoyable
and it really did dot on me like how
what the direction of The Voice work
must be like for Vin Diesel to be
voicing group because you really do get
you know what he's saying yeah a lot of
the time and even though he just has
says I am Groot but the the wide
varieties of the like certain lines like
got you you know you know yeah yeah yeah
right there yeah you know what he's
saying even though all he has says I am
Groot but but it's because of that
variety of different delivery and that
also presents uh like it's like the same
three words yet it could be really funny
a variety of ways and I do like I said I
am liking the darker sensibilities to
just kind of come unexpectedly and yeah
and and the different tones that you're
getting it's it's it is really enjoyable
and I like picking up on on things
without it relying on dialogue forwards
this is like short and sweet and cute as
they are there's so that is very like
beautiful and Escapist about it yeah
like they kind of have the best of of
what I associate with like classic
animated shorts which is yeah they're
like very fun and quirky and they're
very visually driven and they're very
imaginative and you know beautiful
obviously but there is that sense of
sort of rhiness and and like you said
dark humor that I think is really well
pitched here because it's like kids will
absolutely enjoy these and have fun with
these and will probably not really
register some of those darker tones but
the darker tones that are there feel
appropriate to the character but also
definitely like something more to aimed
towards us yeah it's like it's like my
cob humor yeah yeah exactly and it's in
character and it's within the universe
but it strikes this really nice balance
where like the Whimsy and the lightness
and the cuteness makes total sense and
doesn't feel out of place whatsoever and
yet it still doesn't feel that far
removed from the rest of the MCU yeah
yeah so like yeah even though these
aren't like setting up major you know
Easter egg threads or whatever they're
gonna become hugely important that we
know of I mean you got the rebirth
journey and then you got I guess when he
learned to dance yeah yeah what do you
got his legs back you got a little pot
he learned how to dance yeah yeah
um found a fashion style too anyway yeah
yeah exactly we're gonna watch the next
two but before we head out let's do a
patreon
Chase Gardner guess what buddy today
it's your shout out because we're in the
world of a little tree man he's got a
little Bonsai friend you're the perfect
person to come help out Bonsai you are
the Mr Miyagi racism
I don't know what your ethnic background
is
I don't know the more people in this
world than Mr Miyagi work with bonsai
trees but you know you would be the
perfect person if Groot had to have
anybody other than the Guardians of the
Galaxy to look after him to be His
companion it would be you chase Gardner
because you are a friendly caring
good-hearted person but you know you
take care of business when you need to
because that's what gardening's about
pulling the weeds but nurturing the
foliage you know how did I miss there's
a gardener or the Galaxy joke right
there so I hope you're doing well I hope
you're nurturing your own life and we
love you and we'll catch you soon catch
you soon Chase thanks for being here
[Music]